[Musica]
buongiorno
oggi parliamo di sostenibilità
sostenibilità significa ricercare un
equilibrio per aggiunge oggi e preparare
un futuro desiderabile un equilibrio tra
tre dimensioni che devono svilupparsi
insieme ambientale economica e sociale
nei mesi di rock da questo equilibrio è
saltato l'inquinamento stato ridotto e
c'è stato quindi un miglioramento
nell'ambito della sostenibilità
ambientale
ma abbiamo avuto dei contraccolpi dalla
sostenibilità economica e in quella
sociale con aziende chiuse e lavoratori
in cassa integrazione
d'altro canto se avessimo ottenuto le
tende aperte per favorire la
sostenibilità economica avremmo
rischiato la salute e quindi la
sostenibilità sociale decisioni
difficili come queste anche se
ovviamente su scala più ridotta si
presentano in continuazione
da anni però sappiamo che non può
esserci una forma di sostenibilità senza
che siano sviluppate almeno in parte le
altre due è evidente ormai che la
sostenibilità non può passare dal
buttare uno dei tre linee che dalla
torre perché si trascinerebbe con se
anche gli altri
tra le tre dimensioni la dimensione la
cenerentola quella più trascurata è la
sostenibilità sociale perché non è
sostenuta né interessi organizzati come
la sostenibilità economica ma nemmeno da
movimenti e forme di attivismo e che
negli ultimi anni sono finalmente
riusciti a far sentire la propria voce
rispetto alla sostenibilità ambientale
oggi quindi voglio mettere la
sostenibilità sociale per faccende
rendola sotto il riflettore è la
sostenibilità sociale è un processo
dinamico che può essere però ricondotto
a 222 fattori principali l'uguaglianza
sociale e la comunità l'uguaglianza
stare fermo
vito a processi di rimozione delle forme
di discriminazione esclusione sociale
oggi però ci concentriamo sulla comunità
e di comunità si parla si discute fin
dai tempi di aristotele
ma negli ultimi anni proprio cambiato
pelle assunto nuovi significati ed è
tornata al centro dell'attenzione e
nelle prime definizioni di comunità
elemento centrale per la definizione era
un elemento oggettivo la condivisione di
uno spazio fisico
la fusione delle tecnologie digitali ha
poi ormai da alcuni decenni generato
dalle comunità dove lo spazio non è
necessariamente fisico ma può essere
anche digitali negli anni 90 quando
hanno fatto la loro comparsa e le
abbiamo definite comunità virtuali ed
all'inizio venivano definite come poste
a quelle reali con un'accezione negativa
vedono ormai ci è chiaro che la
divisione digitale è integrata con
quella fisica
io sono una sociologa economica nello
studiare le comunità mi sofferma in
particolare sulle comunità economiche
anche digitali e ci sono comunità di
pratiche tra professionisti che svolgono
la stessa attività e si scambia
informazione conoscenza e le prime sono
state quelle dei venditori che avrebbero
tanto da insegnare oggi alle aziende
distribuite o anni sono quelle che
stanno rafforzando lo smart work per
esempio ci sono poi delle comunità di
brand tra consumatori pensate per fare
un esempio la forza della community dei
clienti della lingua e per esempio le
community di consumatori che scambiano
informazioni su offerte su sconti ci
sono una comunità di produzione consumo
come i gruppi di acquisto solidale o la
nuova versione digitale attraverso
piattaforme che permettono l'acquisto km
zero e con i nuovi finanziamenti o tre
tra ha ri negli ultimi mesi abbiamo
sentito tutti parlare di charles farli
con riferimento alle campagne
finanziamento degli ospedali a febbraio
se ci usa invece una campagna che molto
interessante proprio dal punto di vista
economico è una campagna del
rifinanziamento di una di un forno che
il forno precisa è che ha raccolto un
milione 200 mila euro attraverso il
finanziamento condivisa
ecco quando parliamo di comunità quindi
non basta lo spazio fisico serve altro
gli elementi che di solito usiamo per
definire una comunità sono tre il primo
è l'appartenenza non c'è comunica senza
che una persona sento ad appartenere a
questa comunità è provato che recarci
quali sono le comunità di cui voi fate
parte
e poi c'è un secondo elemento ci sono i
riti e le tradizioni e in questi mesi
sull'università adesso e molti studenti
hanno sofferto al momento della laurea e
non poter fare un salto dalle siepi che
ho rito di passaggio e per segnare
proprio e da un lato l'appartenenza alla
comunità dall'altra anche appunto il
passaggio momenti diversi della vita di
queste comunità e marine è già un terzo
elemento che è il debito normativo e il
fatto che ci sentiamo in dovere nei
confronti dei membri delle altre
comunità e questo è evidente nelle
comunità digitali per esempio quando
pensiamo ai meccanismi di reputazione e
perché ci sentiamo in dovere di lasciare
una un giudizio una valutazione dopo
aver fatto uno scambio su una
piattaforma di beni e servizi digitali
pronome non in senso di reciprocità la
reciprocità un elemento importante negli
ultimi mesi le comunità
visto profonde trasformazioni quelle
distanziamento sociale quello che è
successo è che le comunità più forti
hanno trovato un modo per mantenere i
propri legami anche in digitale è un
esempio sono non so a livello aziendale
che abbiamo organizzato dei momenti
informali come il caffè vegetale per
mantenere appunto lo scambio relazionale
tra i propri dipendenti
ma le relazioni le comunità hanno un
ruolo importantissimo anche per le
attività commerciali è un esempio
interessante sono i bond che sono stati
emessi con questo nome
para finanziare dai ristoranti che
andate sostanzialmente dei bar c'era
clienti fidelizzati disposti a pagare il
marcio nel momento in cui restò rendere
ancora acceso e con l'idea che poi
sarebbero andati a cena al momento della
riapertura era ovviamente con un
meccanismo di reciproci nava questi
ristoranti hanno in qualche modo
compensato magari offrendo una cena per
due anziché per una persona alla
situazione che hanno dimostrato di
essere fidelizzate a quell attività
commerciali e legami forti quindi quelli
consolidati non solo dal punto di vista
affettivo anche dal punto di vista
economico commerciale hanno trovato un
modo per mantenere i propri legami
la questione più delicata invece è stata
è e sarà nei prossimi mesi come creare
nuovi legami e il prezzo dei di nuovi
legami passa anche da momenti di
casualità da occasioni non pianificati
da momenti informali e questa occasione
permettono di creare quelli che
definiamo legami tivoli che cosa sono i
legami deboli legami deboli sono quei
legami
con persone che frequentiamo fuoco che
abbiamo a casa devi vedere poche volte
comunque non c'è un legame affettivo
forte e marche sono importantissime
perché da quelle ideali anche se non
passano supporto in ultimo passo un
altro risorsa fondamentale che sulle
informazioni e di particolari
informazioni non ridondati informazione
nuove mentre dalle comunità dense dai
legami più forti
passano le informazioni ridondanti ci
ripetiamo sempre le stesse informazioni
allora è come fare avendo perso
l'occasionalità la casualità degli
incontri non pianificati a costruire
nuovi legami a costruire legami tegoli
molto passa di nuovo dallo spazio vien
detto che la prima definizione di
comunità è legata uno spazio dello
spaccio continua ad essere rilevante è
lo stesso però potrebbe non essere
quello a cui siamo abituati e con lo
smart working abbiamo visto la chiusura
degli uffici ma non per questo le
persone sono costrette per esempio
lavorare da casa e si possono da un lato
ripensare gli uffici come degli spazi
che non sono sono dedicati ai dipendenti
dall'azienda ma possono contaminarsi con
il territorio e dall'altra pensare dei
nuovi luoghi ibridi e magari vicino
all'abitazione delle persone dove poter
andare a lavorare ma non viene per poter
incontrare persone conoscenze
informazioni i prossimi mesi sono
saranno importanti saranno difficili non
dobbiamo nasconderci roma saranno
importanti perché ci permetteranno di
rimettere in discussione il dato per
scontato e di riprogettare ripensare il
nostro futuro e mettendo in campo anche
una capacità di desiderare la capacità
di aspirare che è individuare ma può
essere anche collettiva e qui torniamo
alle nostre comunità
nel ripensare il futuro post coid
diventa fondamentale ripensare le nostre
comunica rimettere al centro la
sostenibilità sociale e insieme alla
sostenibilità sociale anche quella
economica e ambientale perché il rischio
nei prossimi mesi lo sappiamo è che la
crisi sanitaria avendo determinato lo
stiamo vedendo una crisi economica porti
a concentrare tutta l'attenzione sulla
sostenibilità economica con rischio di
buttare dalla torre di cui parlavamo e
la sostenibilità ambientale e di
dimenticarsi invece di quella sociale
quindi proviamo a immaginare un uomo
l'equilibrio tra queste tre forme e
proviamo a farlo insieme a partire dalla
quotidiane ai a partire dalle nostre
comunità
[Musica]